[music]
>> Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Robbi sohri sodri wayassirli amri wahlul
uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qauli Amma
ba'd.
I would like to greet you all with
Islamic greeting Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
My name is Abdul Malik Badeges.
My grandfather comes from Yemen.
But my grandmother comes from Cianjur.
It's a remote area
around 90 km from Jakarta, the capital
city of Indonesia. But I was born there
and raised in Indonesia. So I speak
Bahasa Indonesia.
In 2006,
I graduated from uh senior high school.
And at that time, I couldn't continue to
the university.
I had to work.
I work as an admin and I joined so many
organizations because I really wanted to
learn Islam.
And in 2007,
I got accepted from the University of
Indonesia, Faculty of Humanities,
majoring Arabic literature.
But at that time,
the Arabic literature in my university
is little bit different.
We take the books from
English-speaking countries like America,
Australia. We learn linguistics,
phonetics, phonology from those
countries, not from Saudi Arabia or
Arab
countries.
So, when I graduated in 2011,
I really wanted to continue my study
because I really want to learn Islam.
I really want to learn this. I wasn't
satisfied with the knowledge that I had
at that time.
And before that, in 2009,
I have joined for 3 years for the
Islamic Youth Club in the University of
Indonesia.
And at that time, I was asked by my
brother,
"Malik, do you want to join Islamic
Youth Club?" I said, "Why?" Because
there was nobody wanted to join this
Islamic Youth Club in the University of
Indonesia.
So, I was so sad. How come Indonesia is
the majority of Muslim in the world,
but there was nobody wanted to join
Islamic Youth Club in the University of
Indonesia. So, I joined that
Islamic Youth Club.
And in 2009, I invited a converted
Muslim young Muslim scholar named Ustad
Felix Siauw.
He converted
from a Christian, but he could deliver
Arabic the ayah very well. So, I was
ashamed.
I was I'm Muslim, but I cannot do that.
But the this converted Muslim scholar
can deliver ayah very well. So, that's
why I decided to continue my study in
2011. I went to Malaysia to learn
Islamic economics.
But then again,
I wasn't satisfied.
I graduated in 2013,
and then there was this event.
I really wanted to learn Islam from the
authorized Muslim scholar named Dr.
Zakir Naik.
Thank you very much for the opportunity
for me. I really want to learn a lot
from you, and I want to go back to my
home country because a lot of Muslim in
Indonesia, they do not really practice
Islam.
They don't really pray.
So, only a few of them who pray five
times.
So, that is the situation in my home
country. So, I don't join this event, so
maybe there was nobody from Indonesia.
So, it's a critical situation in
Indonesia. Most of the scholars on TV
are they are those who are popular.
Those who are popular with less
knowledge. Sometimes when we ask them a
question, they will answer in a very
funny way. Well, they're talking about
our religion, Islam.
So, that's why I really wanted to join
this event and alhamdulillah I got
accepted and I really want to learn and
learn and I want to be a knowledgeable
Muslim. Thank you very much, Dr. Zakir
Naik. Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Alhamdulillah. Was salatu was salam ala
rasulillah wa alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in.
Amma ba'd. A'udhu billahi minash
shaytanir rajim. Bismillahir rahmanir
rahim. Rabbishrahli sadri wa yassirli
amri wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu
qawli.
My name is Rehman Younus.
I have pursued my MBBS from China and
right now I'm pursuing my specialization
in the in the field of radiology.
And alhamdulillah I was born in Jeddah,
Saudi Arab in the year of 1990.
And alhamdulillah it was the first time
in 2006
when my father he took me to
that was a lecture by Dr. Zakir Naik in
2006.
It was for two day. On the first day my
father told me we have to go here, but I
was making some excuses that I want I
don't want to go there. I don't want to
attend, but later my father said I'm
your father
and when I say you something you have to
follow me. So, then after all I made
after all my excuses were done, my
father took me. And on the first day
when I listened to Dr. Zakir that was an
Urdu lecture and after listening to the
lecture that lecture has changed me
totally.
And after the And after the completion
of the lecture, I said my father,
"Tomorrow I'll come here by any means.
By any means I would be attending the
second day." And after that inshallah,
then I It was the first time when I went
to China in 2007.
And there I had a subject by called
health education. And my teacher he told
me, "You have to give a similar kind of
talk for you just one or two minutes.
You can choose any topic you want. Any
topic." So, then I went and asked him,
"Can I talk on topic of Islam?" He said,
"Of course you can. If you you I said
any topic, so you can just pick on any
topic." So, after that then I I was just
uh wondering what could I speak? Then
alhamdulillah on the YouTube I found the
a topic on scientific miracles in Quran
by Dr. Zakir Naik. And it was in my
class and we had a strength of about 100
students. And I was totally like
unprepared. I was so nervous on that
day.
And when I when I went on the stage and
I delivered this speech by Dr. Zakir
Naik about scientific miracles,
after I finished, imagine I was the
first one to score the number one in my
in my whole this strength of 100
students, I was the number one. It was
all due to all Allah's help and what
I've learned from Dr. Zakir Naik. And
then alhamdulillah, there were a lot of
Muslims Sorry, there were a lot of
non-Muslims who used to come and ask me
a questions, but I couldn't reply them.
What I used to do, I just used to
download some videos of from YouTube Dr.
Sheikh Dr. Zakir Naik and just used to
present them. With this little effort
what I've done, alhamdulillah there were
four people non-Muslims who accepted
Islam. Alhamdulillah. And out of this
proportion three were non-Muslim girls
and one was a Muslim boy a non-Muslim
boy who reverted back to Islam.
Alhamdulillah being touched with them,
they asked me some questions and
alhamdulillah
then in 2014 in November I met Dr. Zakir
Naik in person in Shanghai.
Alhamdulillah, it was so uplifting to
meet and alhamdulillah I've learned a
lot.
And before coming here alhamdulillah,
I've made a a of dua alhamdulillah and
been selected for this. And I thank each
and every one, especially Dr. Zakir Naik
and the members of the team IRF for
selecting me in this program. I'm really
thankful to Allah subhana wa ta'ala for
being with me. Wa akhir al-da'wani
alhamdulillah rabbil alamin.
Bismillah al-Rahman al-Rahim.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi ta'ala
wabarakatuh.
To my beloved brothers,
basically my name is Zamri Vinod. I came
from Malaysia. Even though I look like
Indian, I'm not Indian.
So, I'm from Malaysia and I'm from
Negeri Sembilan.
So, well, let I tell about myself first.
I'm married. Of course, with my first
wife, I have two children.
And I not yet have second wife yet.
Okay. So,
I converted to Islam. I reverted to
Islam at the age of 16.
And now I'm still 16.
Do you know why?
Because after I become Muslim, it's like
a
newborn baby, is it?
So, I started to count my age from that
time again. So, I'm still 16 now. So, if
you add on together, I'm 32.
Okay.
So, I just want to tell about myself.
Basically, we have an organization in
Malaysia called by Squad Mubaligh.
And in Squad Mubaligh Malaysia,
of course, I'm the I'm the president of
Squad Mubaligh Malaysia. We have We have
three
uh what they call
uh we have uh three
in in three state in Malaysia. We We
have Squad Mubaligh in three state.
And and we have a Mubaligh TV. It is not
it is not as big as Peace TV.
And it is very small and even maybe
maybe 1% out of it. But, I got that
inspiration out of Peace TV because I
was interested to give da'wah through
through media.
And what we have done, there is a
politician named by Lim Kit Siang, YB
Lim Kit Siang in Malaysia. So, we have
done a video.
We asked him to become a Muslim.
And that video was circulated over in
Malaysia. And alhamdulillah, because I I
feel in Malaysia, when we talk about
religion, it is quite sensitive.
You see, so we want to make a mood that
everybody can talk about religion and it
shouldn't it shouldn't be any any
problem.
Okay, then after I become Muslim and
alhamdu- alhamdulillah, last year
my whole family have become a Muslim.
And my last brother have converted as a
as a Islam with the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And inshallah, I believe when I become a
Muslim, there is something that I
discover about Islam. And I want
everybody, each single person in this
world should discover Islam.
As I told my brother,
if he know what I know, I believe he
also will become a Mus- Islam. And he he
also will become a Muslim. And
alhamdulillah, he also have reverted as
a Muslim. So, inshallah, basically, I
learn a lot of things with the student
of Dr. Zakir Naik, which is
brother Shakir.
So, I'm a student of his student. And
now I'm standing in front of you as your
student, sir.
Inshallah. Thank you. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi ta'ala wabarakatuh.
Bismillah rahman rahim.
Alhamdulillah rabbil alamin.
Allahumma salli ala Muhammad wa ala ali
Muhammad. Rabbishrahli sadri wa yassirli
amri. Wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu
qawli.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
My dear respected brothers, my name is
Muhammad Fadli
bin Burhan. I'm from Singapore.
A country that is
um that what is forbidden actually to
the public.
And alhamdulillah, by Allah's grace,
we have managed to do dakwah within the
four walls of the masjid.
And we have set up a team called One God
SG or otherwise known as Singapore
Street Dakwah.
We're doing dakwah within the four
walls. And alhamdulillah, we're getting
tourists and also locals to come on
board and to understand Islam.
I come on board this training for one
reason is to improve on our dakwah
towards the non-Muslim.
And I would like to thank IRF
and Mr. Dr. Dr. Zakir Naik for this
wonderful event that they have put all
the energy and effort into it to make it
a successful one.
I don't come from a background that is
colorful or rather I should say is black
and gray. I come from the dark side of
the world
where
most of my friends
uh
those with tattoos.
So, other than giving dakwah to the
non-Muslims in Singapore,
on the other side I do dakwah to the
gangsters.
It may not be an easy task,
but alhamdulillah, with Allah's help,
some of the gangsters who were born
Muslims are starting to come back to
Islam.
Alhamdulillah.
By then,
I hope we are here to support each other
and give each other encouragement and
take not this as a competition,
inshallah.
I'm wishing all the best for all of us.
May Allah bless us with good ilmu,
inshallah. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
La
ilaha illallah.
>> [music]
>> All right.
All right.
All [music] right.
>> [music]
>> All right.
All right.